mesdames messieurs l'équipe de France
est en finale de la Coupe du Monde bravo
ça fait plaisir non mais franchement
non mais on annonce pas souvent des
bonnes nouvelles mais quand elles sont
comme ça font profiter quoi franchement
c'est bon on a vibré ou pas pas trop on
va pas se planter hein
c'est assez tendu voilà mais le deuxième
but est venu au bon moment pour pour
nous rassurer nous offrir une fin de
match assez tranquille je vais pas faire
le rabat-joie moi je me suis un peu
ennuyé pour tout vous dire et j'ai pas
dit sur une qualification non mais
justement je veux pas commencer par ça
on y viendra après si Nicole ménardes du
chroniqueuse télé radio foot vous êtes
notamment sur le sur RTL Vincent Duchêne
du Figaro journaliste à l'édition et
puis Cédric Ali évidemment service de
sport vous réagissez on passe la soirée
ensemble on sera au Qatar dans un
instant avec Vincent rozeron il est sur
place et on va pouvoir avoir les
premières réactions des supporters
français
[Rires]
je suis très fier très bon match et
effectivement mon deuxième période on
est très bien démarré avec les full
violences habituelles débattées mais
après on a eu un petit moment où
effectivement on était tous très tendu
parce que on voyait pas on voyait
vraiment les Marocains de jouer
complètement du côté français donc il y
avait quand même une période un peu
difficile mais finalement il y a eu des
très belles choses dans ce deuxième
période je trouve
du football parce qu'on va parler foot à
un moment ou un autre mais là l'émotion
c'est un moment historique deuxième
final consécutive c'est rare hein enfin
certains l'ont fait le Brésil en a fait
trois de suite l'Allemagne on a fait
trois de suite la France n'avait jamais
fait de finale consécutifs de suite
on n'a jamais vu ça dans le football
Thibault je prêche un convaincu on l'a
vécu dans le handball bien sûr dans le
foot c'est assez c'est assez
extraordinaire de de pouvoir vivre ça et
puis et puis oui et puis ça ça
récompense enfin il y a des il y a des
joueurs comme Giroud comme des champs
comme Varane comme Lloris c'est c'est
beau et puis il y a cette finale qui une
annonce grandiose face à Messi avec tout
ce que ça représente derrière c'est
c'est tellement bien d'être dans ce
rendez-vous et d'être voilà de vibrer
encore un match de plus bon magnifique
cette équipe et hors du commun je
voudrais commencer par ça avant de se
pencher sur les joueurs les uns après
les autres est-ce qu'on a déjà vu dans
l'histoire du foot une équipe atteindre
la finale en jugement aussi peu je dis
pas mal je dis peu on joue pas on joue
pas on joue pas au foot quoi finalement
et puis on gagne tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps Cindy est-ce que
vous avez un souvenir vous et pas
peut-être pas remonter dans les années
30 mais d'une équipe qui laisse le jeu
et qui dit vous inquiétez pas on gagnera
comme ça même sans jouer
ça et en fait c'est toujours ça qui
réussit à Didier Deschamps c'est qu'on
arrive à rendre ces matchs qui ont l'air
très difficile on arrive à les rendre
finalement facile à passer mais il faut
pas oublier aussi que l'équipe du Maroc
a été très très forte d'ailleurs c'est
la meilleure équipe je pense africaine
d'une Coupe du Monde de
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a
l'impression que les Français ont
beaucoup subi ont beaucoup de
difficultés mais
Didier Deschamps a toujours la clé une
attitude
un peu de l'entrée de colomanie je me
moquais on était plusieurs là pour tout
vous dire dans Studio que le bonheur
demi-finale de Coupe du Monde des champs
fait entrer une marque sur son premier
ballon Vincent est-ce que vous avez déjà
vu Vincent du chêne une équipe je jouais
aussi peu et être aussi dominatrice du
football mondial non mais c'est
hallucinant non j'ai pas souvenir mais
effectivement il y a 4 ans on n'a pas
fait non plus une coupe du monde et Blue
c'est pour ça je donne même pas
l'exemple sur cette Coupe du Monde de
manière générale l'équipe de France de
Deschamps qu'est-ce qui compte à
l'arrivée
pas de problème donc c'est c'est l'ADN
de des chances c'est la gagne à tout
prix et peu importe le flacon pourvu
qu'on est livré quoi donc
là on a livré et je pense qu'il y aura
ce soir dans les dans les Cédric vous
vous avez déjà vu ça une équipe parce
que vous avez le souvenir d'une équipe
qui n'est pas si forte que ça qui n'a
pas l'air si forte que ça et pourtant
qui domine le foot mondial ah bah on
parlait avec avec Vincent des années 90
moi j'ai le souvenir d'une équipe
italienne qui était quand même pas
flamboyante dans le jeu et puis c'est
vrai donc voilà l'Italie a longtemps eu
cette réputation du catenaccio
c'est-à-dire on met en marque un premier
but et puis après on ferme la boutique
et puis c'est terminé donc donc voilà
c'est il y a eu d'autres d'autres
précédents après c'est vrai que depuis
le début du 21e siècle il y a eu
l'Espagne qui a donné un côté assez
flamboyant l'Allemagne aussi qui avait
un jeu très offensif et puis le Brésil à
la fin du du 21 du 20e siècle début du
21e 3 final de suite c'était quand même
pas mal quoi exactement mais dans les
années 90-80 il y a plein d'exemples de
d'équipes qui qui feraient la boutique
peut-être encore bien plus que l'équipe
de France aujourd'hui Vincent roserand
il est sur place il est devant le stade
Vincent vous avez vécu un grand moment
une demi-finale de Coupe du monde avec
les Bleus qui sont donc qualifiés pour
un grand match face à l'Argentine
racontez-nous votre première impression
là la sortie du stade c'est un grand
match
c'était je sais pas si une demi-finale
de Coupe du monde donc c'est forcément
un grand match déjà pour commencer mais
non effectivement c'est un match tendu
c'était un match qu'on va appeler tendu
heureusement qu'on marque très très vite
à la cinquième minute avec The
worlandaise parce que derrière ça a été
compliqué mais vraiment très compliqué
on sait on a même pensé au bout d'un
moment qu'on allait se faire punir au
bout d'un moment de de pas réussir à
mettre ce deuxième but de de ne pas y
arriver et finalement voilà Randa
Colomiers sur son premier ballon qui
barque le coaching vraiment gagnant de
Didier Deschamps sur ce coup-là et à
partir de là on a été vraiment soulagé
on va dire et vous voyez les
statistiques de cette rencontre les
Bleus mènent s'imposent de zéro sans
avoir la possession de balle assez
largement en ayant tiré à peu près
autant de fois que les clés marocains
nous sommes également sur les
Champs-Élysées Timothée delaime vous
êtes sur place les supporters sont
heureux on imagine que ce soir les gens
vont se remplir une première fois on
l'espère avant dimanche racontez-moi
l'ambiance autour de vous
absolument Thibault les champs qui sont
en train de se remplir c'était assez
calme pendant pendant tout le match et
dès le coup de siffler final on a
entendu des klaxons les premiers coups
de sirène de la part des camions de CRS
et les supporters
[Applaudissements]
voilà beaucoup
vous savez quoi
vous savez quoi j'ai j'ai envoyé
Timothée j'ai demandé que Timothée sur
les champs juste pour voir ça voilà
juste pour le voir se faire sauter
dessus bon j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
supporters marocains aussi avec vous on
va voir si vous nous trouvez des des
supporters français qui petit à petit
arrivent et viennent sur les sur les
Champs-Élysées euh je salue tous ceux
qui nous rejoignent Yoda la force est
avec nous nous dit-il ma falda on y est
tout ça en majuscule dit aussi que vous
portez également
Timothée qu'on entend voilà Nathan il
souffle lui parce que c'est vrai que
c'est un soulagement on passe l'après
match ensemble on va retourner voir
Vincent roseron j'espère que lui aussi
nous trouver des supporters français je
vous lance un petit défi mon cher
Vincent bon on parle de cette équipe de
Deschamps exceptionnelle Didier
Deschamps franchement Cédric est-ce que
on peut ça peut plus être de la chance
ça peut pas être de la chance
personnellement ça fait longtemps que je
pense que c'est plus de lâche encore la
chance elle est surtout elle est au
niveau du tirage au sort après c'est
vrai qu'il a eu souvent des groupes qui
étaient très abordables par contre sa
science du groupe
savoir enfin quand il était joueur il
était déjà comme ça et entraîneur
sélectionneur il a il a encore développé
et c'est vrai que faire rentrer colo
Moigny alors qu'on aurait pu penser que
c'était Comane qui aurait dû remplacer
Dembélé bien sûr c'est un coup qui
semble bizarre et qui devient un coup de
génie et c'est plus un hasard c'est
c'est vraiment Didier Deschamps qui est
qui est pour moi le plus grand
sélectionneur que l'équipe de France est
jamais eue largement et d'une certaine
manière il restait toujours Jacquet dans
l'imaginaire bien sûr mais dans la durée
dans tout ce que réalise Didier
Deschamps aujourd'hui une certaine
manière l'un des plus grands hommes de
l'histoire des Bleus peut-être le numéro
1 peut-être l'un des plus gros
sélectionneurs même de l'histoire de
l'équipe de France 98 dans l'histoire de
l'équipe de France Didier Deschamps et
peut-être le numéro 1 devant tous les
autres joueurs vous voyez ce que je veux
dire en tant que capitaine sélectionneur
c'est exceptionnel Vincent vous en
pensez quoi Didier Deschamps ce soir il
fait les bons choix une fois de plus bon
bah ça tombe du ciel non il a beaucoup
de réussite et effectivement parce que
vous n'êtes pas tout à fait d'accord
pour vous au bout d'un moment là il fait
rentrer que le moisi et bim sur son
premier ballon c'est ça fait but on va
pas dire que c'est la science de des
chances et quand même un maximum de
réussite le penalty de Kane raté c'est
quand même un maximum de réussite aussi
donc il y a quand même une charge
franchement je vous le dis je me mets à
croire que non je me mets à croire que
non
en phase finale de Coupe du monde pour
les champs il devient le deuxième
sélectionneur avec le plus de victoire
de l'histoire du foot c'est pas 14 coups
de chance
ces changements tactiques parce que là
on a vu que tous ces changements sont
finalement gagnants et puis même les
personnes qui met sur les terrains les
joueurs parce que quand on parle par
exemple dans connaître et vous m'aurez
dit peut-être il y a peut-être des
sélectionnésie non c'est difficile on
est pas sélectionné mais là un joueur
comme ça d'un mètre 94 qui arrive
vraiment à être patron dans la défense
on nous a été très utile déjà face à
l'Australie et là face à ces matchs là
moi je trouve qu'il y a pas de hasard
c'est vraiment c'est choix
sur Le Figaro.fr allez les bleus en
route pour la troisième étage Vincent
roseron vous êtes avec un supporter ça a
l'air plus calme est-ce qu'il est
heureux celui-ci
alors je vais lui demander est-ce que
vous êtes heureux du mal est-ce que vous
êtes franco-marocain est-ce que vous
êtes heureux de ce match bah écoutez
heureux oui et non enfin non parce que
mon cœur est marocain après comme je
vous ai dit on est franco-marocain
c'était une très belle partie
résultat des courses comme je le dis
c'est que c'est une victoire pour tous
pour le Qatar je tiens à souligner
surtout pour le Qatar parce qu'une
organisation telle c'est du jamais vu je
suis là depuis le début de la Coupe du
Monde il y a aucun incident tout le
monde est heureux les stades sont pleins
c'est la fête tous les jours matin et
soir donc c'est exceptionnel maintenant
que le Maroc est éliminé ben on attend
la finale avec impatience pour que bah
les Bleus la remportent est-ce que
est-ce qu'on peut se dire que
demi-finale j'imagine vous vous êtes
déçu mais une demi-finale pour le Maroc
c'est quand même génial alors c'est vrai
que nos journalistes ou nos enfin nos
journalistes français ou européens
disent que c'est exceptionnel vu le
niveau de chaque joueur marocain je
pense qu'ils sont à leur place ils
auraient pu mieux faire ils ont un
entraîneur exceptionnel ils ont un
groupe exceptionnel et comme je vous
l'ai dit tous les joueurs sont dans les
plus grands clubs européens l'Académie
Mohamed VI fait un travail
extraordinaire donc ils sont à leur
place c'est un beau parcours c'est un
excellent parcours c'est une première
pour le Maroc et la suite va être belle
très bien merci beaucoup en tout cas
voilà Thibault pour ce premier tu as vu
je vais essayer de trouver aussi des
supporters français bien évidemment mais
comme vous le voyez ici il y a 95% et on
l'a vu pendant le stade 95% des
supporters ici sont vraiment super Mario
français vous inquiétez pas vous nous la
faites pas Vincent on a vu des
supporters français dans le stade vous
êtes encore mal placé à la sortie du
stade je le sais bon allez je vous fais
confiance vous nous trouvez du monde
blog AX qui nous dit on va taper
l'Argentine en finale voilà bon j'espère
évidemment et on va se projeter Didier
Deschamps dans on a parlé je voudrais
parler pour moi selon moi de l'homme du
match côté bleu Antoine Griezmann ah on
est tous d'accord là dessus pour une
fois qu'on a l'air d'accord non c'est
une dialogue il a été exceptionnel mais
de toute façon c'est un dur il a défendu
il a dit les au terrain il a attaqué
enfin il est il est omniprésent et puis
c'est vrai que des fois on a du mal à
lui reconnaître mais c'est vraiment les
gens qui a été le plus en plus je pense
si ce n'est que aussi bapé en deuxième
période il faut pas aligner il avait
trois quatre jours sur lui ça a été un
festival il a été excellent j'ai
l'impression qu'on a pas vu le même
match franchement non mais alors vous
l'avez fait une petite parenthèse Mbappé
on y reviendra après vous avez trouvé
bon Mbappé non mais
sur ce sur cette coupe du monde et
surtout sur sur ces deux sur ces deux
c'est le symbole
oui jamais c'est le symbole de cette
équipe de France c'est une équipe je
sais ce que vous allez me dire il fait
un match très médiocre mais il est
décisif et cette équipe de France fait
des matchs moyens bon médiocre ce que
vous voulez mais elle est décisive donc
voilà et et et
parce que je sais que ça va faire des
bas un peu fait monter la sauce on parle
de Griezmann pour l'instant Cédric votre
avis sur Griezmann on en a plaisanté
tous les deux au moment donné Thibault
on s'est dit je vous ai dit c'est une
bonne idée de décembre d'avoir mis deux
Griezmann sur le terrain parce qu'à un
moment donné j'avais l'impression que il
dégageait le ballon de la tête pour
lui-même qui venait la récupérer ce qui
était partout donc il a été il a été
impressionnant il a été flamboyant et il
a porté le danger plusieurs fois on l'a
vu monter sur le pressing appeler ses
partenaires à ne pas trop reculer cette
période c'est le seul qui l'a fait il
fait le pressing il se retourne et il y
a personne derrière lui c'est un vrai
leader en plus c'est un vrai leader il
en impose et puis et puis seulement ça
fait plaisir de le revoir comme ça après
ce qu'il a vécu l'Atletico de Madrid il
est au top il est au top et peut-être
que finalement ce faible temps de jeu
qu'il a eu un moment donné Atletico de
Madrid fait qu'il est physiquement là il
est il est ah oui Vincent on peut
expliquer ça Madrid il y a l'Atletico il
ne pouvait pas jouer à cause d'une
clause dans un contrat tout à fait et
c'est incroyable ce qui fait là il a il
a un coffre c'est vraiment monstrueux
il a joué 6 il a joué 10 il était il
était vraiment partout qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je dise de plus que que
Cédric incroyable en fait ce qu'il y a
deux ce qu'il y a de magnifiques avec
Griezmann sur cette Coupe du Monde c'est
que on a perdu Ngolo Kanté mais on a on
a Antoine Griezmann qui fait du Ngolo
Kanté d'une certaine façon oui il avait
aussi cette capacité à courir partout
un peu plus haut mais mais remarquez on
a vu Griezmann vachement défendre donc
son système tactique il le fait
descendre un petit peu aussi parce que
n'oublions pas que des bases Griezmann
était plutôt posita et là il s'est
retourné mais j'ai toujours raison
il ne sait pas qu'il a des personnes qui
ont toujours raison vous avez raison
mais j'ai mis un bémol quand même Cindy
c'est un choix Didier Deschamps qui
n'avait pas le choix de le faire
et c'est vrai
oui mais je
pense qu'on entendait dans un autre
média et dans d'autres personnes
effectivement vous informer sur d'autres
médias sur le Figaro
non on est tombé déjà cette tendance des
champs par rapport à au placement des
Griezmann le sait depuis quelque chose
que des champs portent Griezmann c'est
la soutenu qu'il a qui même dans les
moments difficiles qui l'a convaincu de
rester en équipe de France qu'il a enfin
voilà donc qui si et Griezmann pour son
seul passage en conférence de presse
comme l'avait souligné Baptiste des Prés
et Christophe remise à vraiment rendu
hommage à des champs il a dit je fais ça
pour l'équipe de France et pour Didier
Deschamps donc ça ce n'est pas de la
chance non plus c'est Didier Ludovic qui
nous dit 10 pour grise il commence à
donner les notes on va les donner les
notes tout à l'heure
contrairement à d'habitude c'est assez
impressionnant parce que
Antoine Griezmann il en est je crois à
71 titularisation match consécutif avec
les blocs il me semble que c'est ça non
on va demander on va chercher la
statistique
peut-être que vous avez le nombre de
matchs consécutifs joués par Antoine
Griezmann et vous êtes avec un supporter
français et ce beau maillot bleu qui a
et bien porté chance au bleu ce soir
il a porté Chanceaux bleues
effectivement ce beau maillot bleu qui
me permet au beau bleu d'aller jusqu'en
final malgré un match un peu compliqué
on en parlait justement oui un match on
peut compliquer un match au piège on le
savait on a eu la chance de marquer
rapidement ça a changé la physionomie du
match je pense après il a fallu gérer
ses dégâts compliqué c'est étendu donc
après le deuxième but c'était quand même
beaucoup plus relax c'est c'était
vraiment le match piège par excellence
on doit pour la sortie ça pouvait
basculer à tout moment quand même oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai je répète le fait
de marquer tôt ça a quand même changé la
donne ça a obligé les marocains à sortir
tout de suite et donc ça nous a offert
des contre donc c'était bien on aurait
pu le plier plus tôt mais ça on n'a pas
tué le match quand même ouais on a pas
tué le match justement on n'a pas tué le
match mais bon allez on va au final on
va pas faire un film bouge on va
effectivement merci Beaucoup de rien
merci et alors justement parce que vous
parce que vous vous demandez une
statistique mais moi j'en ai une autre
pour vous en fait c'est la 7e Coupe du
Monde depuis 98 et en cette coupe du
monde on est allé quand même quatre fois
au final
ouais merci Vincent facelon lavé de
statistiques merci mais en tout cas vous
êtes là sur tous les ballons je vois
alors je l'ai la statistique je suis
allé chercher là pendant que Vincent
parler avec ce supporter visiblement
c'est cassé la voix et vous vous leur
demanderez au supporter français Vincent
si vous en croisez encore s'il reste
pour la pour la finale comment ça se
passe 72 élections consécutives Antoine
Griezmann on était d'ailleurs 73 et 71
la vérité finalement bon je risque
nicloé trop contente voilà des bonnes
nouvelles et on parlait donc d'Antoine
Griezmann j'ouvre la page Mbappé allez
on y vient euh Macron est en train de
parler évidemment et on l'écoute est-ce
qu'on peut écouter le chef de l'État
on prépare la finale et vous allez
pouvoir et on la gagne vous serez là
dimanche monsieur le Président un mot
sur cette Coupe du Monde au Qatar qui
était très critiqué
des changements
j'ai toujours été éclair sur ce sujet
d'abord il y a des décisions qui sont
prises des années avant quand on
attribue une coupe ensuite quand elle
est là le sport doit rassembler et il en
est des Coupes du Monde de football
comme de rugby comme des Jeux Olympiques
et cela pour rassembler parfois pour que
des nations qui ne savent pas se parler
sur le plan politique se parlait et donc
d'ailleurs j'ai pu voir les miens du
Qatar avant dimanche je reviendrai et il
est prévu plusieurs rendez-vous plus
politique avec d'autres chefs d'État de
gouvernement sur des situations de crise
ensuite il faut reconnaître que le Qatar
l'organisme très bien cette Coupe du
Monde l'organisation est bonne la
sécurité est bonne et donc de dire
ne mégotons pas sur notre plaisir on est
en finale c'est formidable et donc
sachons nous française et français avant
d'avoir des joies simples et être fiers
qu'on doit continuer à régler il y a
plein de pays où il faut régler les
choses et franchement ce soir je suis
fier de l'équipe de France on est tous
fiers en tant que française et français
donc soyons heureux
au Parlement européen
NES Cédric
là maintenant il vient commenter la
victoire de l'équipe de France
ne passons tous enfin voilà je trouve
que c'est quand même assez particulier
de poser des questions comme ça de mon
point de vue là sur ce timing là je
l'entends je comprends ce que voulait
dire mais il a dit ayons des jouets
simples vous devriez prendre exemple sur
ce qui vient de dire Emmanuel Macron ne
boudons pas notre plaisir voilà
[Musique]
violence face à l'Argentine moi je suis
la plus heureuse aujourd'hui vraiment
allez Mbappe tiens un autre jeune qui a
réussi vite après Emmanuel Macron le
fantôme décisif d'une certaine manière
parce que franchement alors sauf vous
c'est une Nicole Ménez vous l'avez vu
très bon vous nous dit d'ailleurs sur le
chat sur YouTube sur Le Figaro.fr quel
niveau vous placez Mbappé dans dans
cette rencontre
il fait deux frappes contrées et deux
fois ça sera terminé en but de Vincent
c'est ce qu'on lui demande c'est d'être
décisif c'est ce qu'il a été après il
fait pas un mauvais match comme l'entend
Cédric je trouve moi je l'ai trouvé
disponible il a cherché la solution il a
vu que c'était fermé à gauche il a
essayé de passer dans l'axe par moment
c'était fermé voilà il a essayé de
trouver des possibilités je les trouvais
disponible il a fait quelques courses
quelques différences balles au pied je
trouve pas qu'il a fait un match mauvais
non non de toute façon déjà quand un
joueur est décisif deux fois enfin c'est
pas possible
après on attend tellement plus il y a
quelques mauvais choix à un moment donné
il y a notamment en première période il
doit il doit il doit la donner à Giroud
et tout seul dans l'axe il préfère la
jouer tout seul
il y a quand même des moments donnés
c'est extraordinaire et j'ai trouvé
meilleur quand il a été replacé dans
l'axe à la sortie de Giroud parce que
vous en avez pensé
à la mi-temps un moment on dit c'est il
poulait également profiter du fait qu'il
est pas trop marqué à la couleur pour
venir se placer un petit peu à l'axe
mais ce que je trouvais bien des des
paper même si nous sommes habitués à
mieux notamment lors de la première
mi-temps mais lors de la seconde
mi-temps et ce qui était bien c'est son
festival là pas la Polo but décoller au
monite c'était vraiment il était un peu
harcelé par trois quatre joueurs et
c'est un festival ce qui nous a fait il
faut quand même les souligner et puis il
y a eu quelques full violences mais
effectivement si on fait dans la
globalité peut-être un peu moins bien
que dans les autres matchs mais il a
fait une très belle coupe du monde
il y en a aussi derrière Vincent roseron
qui lui aussi est au stade des
supporters avec des drapeaux vous voyez
que vous nous en avez trouvé est-ce
qu'ils ont réussi à chanter plus fort
que les Marocains c'est supporters qui
sont forcément heureux Vincent
alors je vais leur demander mais est-ce
que vous avez réussi à chanter plus fort
que les Marocains aujourd'hui je pense
qu'on a chanté un petit peu plus fort
mais seulement dans les cinq dernières
minutes c'était incroyable vraiment
quelle ambiance il y avait une ambiance
de fou à ce match on le savait ils sont
très nombreux c'est énorme et rouge quoi
et ils ont envahi le stade on savait on
l'avait déjà vu dans les Russes ce matin
toute la journée ça a été comme ça et là
on l'a subi on le savait qu'on allait
être en infériorité mais ça nous dérange
pas trop en général de jouer à
l'extérieur donc c'est bien on l'a
encore vu aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que on
parie justement dans l'émission de
Kylian Mbappe comment vous l'avez trouvé
aujourd'hui qu'il y a Mbappé décisif
décisif ok il a été bien musée etc mais
décisif parce qu'il est sur le premier
but il est à l'origine du premier but
derrière landais c'est lui qui frappe et
le deuxième but encore c'est lui qui
frappe et que le moisi qui va donc bah
décisif voilà merci Kilian encore une
fois même si même si Deschamps il a été
très aspiré quand même c'est incroyable
c'est on a quand même souffert en plus
pendant ce match mais on a souffert dans
beaucoup de matchs l'Angleterre on a
souffert on a souffert là il y a que
aller peut-être la Pologne c'était un
peu plus facile encore on se prend un
petit but encore bah là on en prend pas
voilà enfin un match on prend pas de but
on marque ça rassure tout le monde pas
de blesser pas de carton rouge on va
arriver dans de bonnes conditions pour
la finale et évidemment la la gagner
pour la troisième étoile et la question
c'est ce que vous vous allez y aller à
cette finale bien sûr ah une finale il
faut y être c'est obligé là quand on est
à dehors maintenant on y est très bien
merci beaucoup messieurs
merci
vincentaire
j'en ai un autre de supporters
[Applaudissements]
alors vous avez entendu le chef de
l'État il y a un instant mais oui j'ai
entendu le chef de l'État il a dit il a
voulu garder le la réussite en football
et je crois que c'est ça je pense que on
n'arrête pas de vouloir nous expliquer
les choses compliquées que la France a
pas très bien joué que cette coupe du
monde alors là regardez elle est juste à
côté elle est juste à côté de vous c'est
Nicolas elle a cette chance elle a la
chance avec elle et avec la chance on
peut faire beaucoup de choses
moi je suis allez moi je veux qu'on
savour ce moment c'est vraiment ça je
suis d'accord
le début de ce match on se disait
comment ça va vous êtes arrivés sur ce
plateau dans vos petits souliers là vous
arrivez
quoi ouvre un bouton on est bien c'est
des vrais moments de bonheur et je
trouve que ça c'est il y a que le sport
qui peut nous le procurer des moments
comme ça c'est une vraie tragédie
c'est-à-dire qu'on rentre on sait pas
quel sera le scénario non on a la
trouille au ventre on espère nous
Français et les Marocains c'est pareil
que le dénouement serait le bon
dénouement ça se termine bien ça se
termine super bien de zéro moi ça me
rappelle 98 pas un match non plus
exceptionnel la demi-finale et vous avez
raison mais je je pense j'étais petit
mais j'ai réussi cette finale
cette demi-finale il y avait plus de
suspense parce que la France ça souffert
a été menée un zéro avec ce but venu
d'ailleurs se doubler de Lilian Thuram
est-ce que vous êtes pas un peu ennuyé
ce soir un tout petit peu mais alors là
il y a pour tout vous dire
ça non non après à ce moment là je pense
qu'il y a plus de technique il y a plus
de tactique on est en demi-finale d'une
Coupe du Monde l'important c'est de dire
mais ce soir si vous avez vibré comme
vibrer sur les autres demi-finales de
l'équipe de France je vais vous dire ce
que j'ai ressenti le un joie immense à
la troisième minute quand il ouvre la 5e
quand ils ont marqué on s'est dit il
faut qu'il marque pour qu'ensuite on se
fasse une série de comptes regarder les
images en direct devant le stade au
Qatar voilà pendant que vous parlez d'un
collier Martin allez-y je vous laisse
continuer donc après du stress mais on
est oui moi j'étais stressé même si le
match était pas terrible on a pas arrêté
de se dire dis donc ça aurait pu être
mieux il y a eu quelques occasions
ratées et puis après il y a ce deuxième
but de chance il faut quand même me
reconnaître bon le premier il est pas il
est pas mal chanson non plus hein c'est
interdit qui revient dans les Landes et
là il reste 15 20 minutes et on zip
c'est bon c'est 15 20 minutes c'est
c'est le plaisir simple du spectateur
moi je suis pas un spécialiste et je
pense que on a vibré le dénouement est
superbe on est heureux et je sais pas
moi j'ai une petite chose vous le dire
peut-être que je serai déçu dimanche
mais quand on a autant de tout se passe
aussi bien il y a pas de blessés on va
se retrouver avec une équipe complète
depuis cette match parce qu'avant ça
de rabiots on va y parler on parlera de
l'Argentine d'abord je veux qu'on reste
sur ce match si vous voulez je trouve
que le
Fofana a tenu quand même
Konaté aussi finalement que après c'est
intéressant alors je salue tous ceux qui
nous rejoindre puisqu'on est nombreux
sur Youtube et sur le Figaro.fr ce soir
tiens Roger Roger qui nous dit c'est un
beau match lui il pense que c'était une
grande rencontre tiens vous ouvrez donc
ma page après Mbappé le fantôme j'avais
marqué faut fana Konaté merci messieurs
j'ai envie de leur dire parce que
franchement ils sont dans les meilleurs
joueurs de la soirée non ah ouais double
réussite moi je suis
très content pour Fofana parce que
vraiment je je
regarde cette image au centre parce que
et on va la mettre en plein écran si on
peut avec Riad Becker ce que vous voyez
on est devant le stade il y a des
drapeaux français des drapeaux marocains
Riad mettait un peu d'ambiance et on
écoute ce qui se passe devant le stade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est sympa ces images voyez les
Marocains heureux franchement c'est ce
qu'on veut voir sur les Champs-Élysées
aussi ce soir j'espère qu'on verra
partout en France vous voulez qu'on
aille sur les champs d'ailleurs allez on
rejoint Timothée delham Timothée vous
êtes sur les Champs-Élysées est-ce qu'il
y a du monde c'est sombre visiblement en
même temps il fait nuit à Paris comme
partout en France dites-nous quel est
l'ambiance
nous sommes en finale de la Coupe du
Monde ouais Grosso ambiance la Tibo
l'ambiance qui est vraiment en train de
de franchir un palier là avec beaucoup
beaucoup de monde et vous les voyez sur
sur ces images les supporters qui sont
en train de remonter de remonter vers la
salle [ __ ] merci merci nous on arrive
[ __ ] on arrive voilà
[Applaudissements]
l'Argentine on arrive Timothée j'espère
que tout va bien
vous nous faites un petit message il est
là il est là tout va bien voilà dès
qu'il y a des caméras tout de suite un
attroupement c'est le cas avec nous
c'est le cas avec tous les autres médias
que nous avons croisé jusqu'à présent
les supporters évidemment qui ont envie
de partager leur joie de cette
qualification une grosse ambiance en
tout cas avec des
bien évidemment comme de coutume au
niveau de l'Arc de Triomphe qui ont été
allumés tout à l'heure et voilà et les
supporters qui crient on est en finale
on a entendu quelques champs également
et l'ambiance la soirée en tout cas qui
qui ne fait que commencer vous entendez
également ce concert de klaxon qui qui
voilà qui ne s'arrête plus depuis le
coup de finale jusqu'à maintenant et
c'est parti pour une bonne partie de la
nuit en tout cas les supporters qui sont
de plus en plus nombreux ici sur les
Champs-Élysées j'ai l'impression qu'il y
a une bonne ambiance Timothée avec des
supporters marocains on espère que ça va
continuer on est aussi devant le stade
nous sommes partout dans le salon du
Figaro on passe la soir ensemble parce
que cet historique la France est en
finale de la Coupe du monde pour la 4e
fois si mes comptes sont bons ça c'est
une une bonne nouvelle Vincent roseron
on revient un peu au foot tactico
technique
Fofana Konaté les deux entrants il nous
inquiétait un petit peu d'une certaine
manière ils ont été très bons non les
deux
a été XXL je suis entièrement d'accord
avec vous il livre une performance
incroyable vraiment très très solide par
contre Fofana ça a été beaucoup plus
compliqué pour lui défensivement alors
ouais le deuxième but vient un peu de
sable via un peu de son côté quand même
donc on peut lui mettre ça à son crédit
mais vraiment sur ce côté gauche avec
Hernandez il a été en grande grande
difficulté et il nous a fait un peu peur
je veux pas vous le cacher d'accord bon
il a pas aimé Fofana
attendez vous étiez sur quelle chaîne
vous moi j'étais sur
les confrères mais bon d'accord parce
que lui il est au stade donc moi j'ai
plus tendance à le croire lui que vous
mon cher Cédric oui mais mais Vincent a
peut-être du confond de choix béni avec
avec Fofana de temps en temps tout en
haut des tribunes comme ça voilà tu vois
je sois béni faire mon meilleur match tu
vois Amélie faire un meilleur match que
qu'il faut faire
au retour de Vincent roseron à Doha
Vincent je t'attends vous savez ce qu'on
va faire on va faire les notes dans un
instant donc on va pouvoir
tranquillement passer de l'un à l'autre
et voir ce qu'on pense nos internautes
voir ce qu'on pense Baptiste des Prés et
Christophe remise qui sont dans le stade
vous en avez pensé quoi jacolivier de
Fofana et Konaté franchement bon j'ai
trouvé certains les trouve sur
impérial j'ai trouvé d'une certaine
manière la défense parce qu'ils ont
quand même question subsidiaire est-ce
que Konaté doit être titulaire dimanche
c'est des chocs qui décidera puisque
c'est le logiciel
mais si vous deviez lui faire un petit
SMS
j'ai quand même le sentiment globalement
qui avait pas de joueurs qui étaient là
par hasard ils étaient au-delà par
hasard ils ont tenu leur leur place on a
parlé des gens un peu exceptionnels
Konaté à faire très grand match
oui donc je pense qu'il a sa place il a
sa place mais il Fofana qu'on avait vu
vraiment pas très bon contre la Tunisie
a réussi à hisser son niveau de jeu donc
moi je suis je pense que
ça a été solide quand même on aurait pu
prendre des buts on a eu un peu de
chance c'est vrai on a une défense assez
solide je lis ce que je salue déjà les
habitués Charles Martel qui est là qui
nous dit le Maroc manque de buteur et
oui alors cette statistique tout à fait
étonnante l'avant centre marocain
n'a touché que trois ballons en 66000 en
66 Minutes regardez plus faible totale
jamais enregistré depuis 1966 pour un
joueur ayant joué plus de 45 minutes
dans un match de Coupe du monde et j'ai
vu que les autres statistiques le but de
Théo Hernandez a été marqué après il me
semble 4 minutes 37 il me semble que
c'est ça en régie 4 minutes 39 et le
buteur le plus rapide dans une
demi-finale de Coupe du Monde depuis
1958 voilà
voilà depuis le Brésilien Vava sur
connaissez bien en tant qu'observateur
sur le les Marocains j'ai trouvé qu'ils
ont su déborder ils ont su mettre en
danger effectivement
l'équipe de France mais effectivement il
y a manqué de buteurs
numéro 9 qui avait peut-être le meilleur
milieu de terrain global de la
compétition mais qui avait pas un mec
devant qui était capable de faire
différence et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
rendre hommage quand même à Kylian
Mbappé même si on en attend plus même si
on sait qu'il voilà il pourrait en
apporter voilà il est décisif et les
Marocains aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils
auraient bien voulu avoir un petit peu
avec les Marocains c'est que même s'ils
ont été très folles et combatifs ils
sont eu du mal à la finition mais sinon
ils sont fait un très très grand match
on attendait des gens qui défendent bien
sûr ils ont pris un but assez vite
ils ont réussi à se talent de donner la
possession de balle on a les
statistiques à des équipes qui ne la
veulent pas
on n'a pas fait un bon match c'est vrai
qu'on a pas fait un on n'a pas fait un
mauvais match non plus on a pas fait un
gros match on a non voilà 2-0 donc on
fait un bon match vous savez ce qu'on me
dit dans l'oreillette hormis le Costa
Rica le Maroc avait le plus faible taux
de possession de la Coupe du monde et
pourtant contre nous plus de 60 % de
possession étonnant
ils avaient pas de possession et gagner
les matchs ils ont de la possession ils
l'ont perdu voilà exactement laissons la
possession aux argentin dimanche on va
ouvrir la page radio c'est un très très
intéressant on va parler de l'Argentine
évidemment on va se projeter un petit
peu avant ça Vincent roserand est avec
un superbe supporter et je suis obligé
de vous laisser la main à Vincent
effectivement avec un très beau bonnet
quand même il faut il faut le voir il
faut le voir ce modèle vraiment au jour
là c'est quoi qui sort de ce match pour
vous après ce match ça a été très très
difficile la deuxième mi-temps
irrespirable et puis des gens qui nous
sort un changement donc on ne
s'attendait pas parce que normalement
c'est comment qui rentre à la place de
Dembélé et puis une minute même pas 20
secondes 30 secondes après que le
monique est là au bon endroit au bon
moment magnifique magnifique on n'avait
pas raviaux on n'avait pas ou pas mécano
Fofana et Konaté vous allez être comment
pendant ce match incroyable ils ont fait
le job ils ont été des patrons comme
comme depuis deux mois on a des blessés
à tue-tête et puis ça se passe toujours
donc c'est c'est magnifique et je pense
honnêtement il y a pas grand chose qui
peut nous arriver la finale alors déjà
la finale est-ce que vous allez y aller
et et ensuite vous vous voyez quoi ce
match contre l'Argentine être un peu
plus compliqué que celui-là ça va être
compliqué mais pas plus que l'Angleterre
et pas plus que le Maroc je ne pense pas
parce que le Maroc était très très fort
défensivement on a le but tout de suite
donc ça nous a changé la physiologie du
mal vis-à-vis du match pardon mais merci
mais honnêtement non non j'ai pas plus
peur que ça de l'Argentine l'Angleterre
était très très forte le Maroc aussi on
a c'est une finale de Coupe du Monde on
a l'expérience d'en avoir joué une il y
a 4 ans avec 4 5 joueurs qui sont encore
titulaires
ça va le faire très bien merci beaucoup
vous ne relâchez pas supporter attendez
vous me le rattrapez s'il vous plaît
Vincent faites demi-tour oui oui non
vous me le rattrapez je récupère voilà
est-ce que vous faites c'est que vous
lui demandez s'il peut vous prêter son
chapeau s'il vous plaît
non je n'oserais pas je n'oserais pas
c'est c'est pour vous prendre votre
chapeau mais je vais pas le faire parce
que quand même c'est son porte-bonheur
désolé Thibault vous ne me verrez pas
avec ce magnifique chapeau sur moi je
suis désolé il y a une petite déception
je suis très content qu'on apprend que
l'Argentine parce que je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez mais avant la Coupe
du monde les supporters j'entends on
fait une chanson raciste contre Mbappé
et je suis très content qu'on les
affrontent parce que le karma il répare
toujours les choses et je pense que
Mbappé il va avoir une fin de malade
pour réparer cet afro plus un titre de
meilleur joueur du Mondial qui va jouer
c'est ça entre Killian et Léo donc que
le meilleur gagne et on espère qu'il
sera français comme ça on enlèvera ce
maillot là puis on en rajoutera une
troisième ici super merci beaucoup
c'est vrai ça positif et alors j'aime
beaucoup ce qui se passe ce soir vous
avez vu la jeune femme avec le drapeau
du Maroc qui est venu dire félicitations
voilà donc on a une très bonne ambiance
ce soir juste un petit mot sur Olivier
Giroud est-ce que ça a été lui le plus
mauvais français ce soir non non à ce
qui bah c'est on a joué à 10 donc si
quelqu'un a des nouvelles d'Ousmane
Dembélé
a été
transparent mais une accélération à un
moment donné elle a dû faire une action
positive dans tout le match on l'a pas
vu c'était une catastrophe alors Olivier
Giroud certes loupe deux occasions
c'est lui qui tire sur le poteau c'est
ça
a été fantomatique il est sorti tôt
encore je le sens tirer la langue
Olivier rouge parce que vous en pensez
il est un peu fatigué non mais c'est
aussi
il nous habitué à tellement grand que
c'est vrai que parfois on a tendance à
oublier
il a un certain âge une certaine
expérience donc c'est bien finalement de
les préserver parce qu'il va nous être
très utile au final
on a vu plusieurs alors oui j'espère que
j'espère qu'il y a rien de rien de
sérieux mais
moi j'ai eu un jeune homme hier c'était
Léo Messi oui il a quel âge 34 35 ans
donc je laisse sentiment que Giraud en
finale ça va ça peut transcender je
pense que s'il a pas besoin d'être de se
transformer dans des événements comme ça
il est sorti et puis finalement il vient
oui c'est tout Gilou ça effectivement
bonne ambiance visiblement sur les
Champs-Élysées et qu'on a Timothée
d'Hélène on dit et on va le voir un peu
pour savoir ce qu'il se passe sur la
plus belle avenue du monde vous voulez
qu'on fasse un peu les notes on les fait
rapidement si ça vous dit après on se
projette sur l'Argentine on commence
alors Vincent roseron tiens pendant que
je cherche le papier comme ça j'ai
toutes les notes de Christoph et
Baptiste des prêts qui se Christophe qui
sont dans le stade vous votre note allez
on commence par le gardien Hugo Lloris
vous me dites quelle note vous lui
donnez pourquoi
[Musique]
alors
alors attendez attendez avant ça je
voulais juste réagir sur Giroud sur la
blessure en fait en première mi-temps
dès le début du match à partir vers la
15e on a senti qu'il était en difficulté
Marcus Thuram est parti à l'échauffement
et on a vraiment pensé qu'il allait
sortir en début de match finalement ça
c'est pas fini sur le terrain mais
effectivement petite alerte j'ai
l'impression du côté d'Olivier Giroud en
première mi-temps ensuite votre question
sur Hugo Lloris bah Hugo Lloris il prend
pas de but pour la première fois de ce
Mondial et Hugo Lloris il a sauvé des
bonnes des beaux ballons je lui mettrais
bien une petite note de 7 7 pour rigoler
parce qu'on est d'accord on signe 7 moi
je suis à 7,5
pour embêter Vincent ronzo merci mon
cher vous êtes
c'est la note qu'on donnait Christophe
remise et Baptiste des prés Jules Kunde
à droite quelle note vous lui donnez
on l'a pas trouvé en attaque sauf un
moment donné où il donne un très bon
ballon mais moi j'aurais dit si c'est
demi pour moi 8 il faudrait il aurait
fallu qu'il apporte plus offensivement
mais mes défensivement il a fait le
boulot
efficace
vous êtes non mais vous êtes on n'a pas
trouvé non plus les Marocains du côté de
coude nez
Christophe lui ont donné 5 la défense
centrale allez on fait le duo là vous
leur donnez combien cette réforme moi
j'aurais dit Konaté j'aurais dit sept
ans et demi et puis Varane si c'est demi
je vous écoute
connecter une très bonne note moi je le
dis OUI tu es banane peut-être tous un 6
7 6 7
pour connaître
que j'ai pas trouvé vraiment
exceptionnel et la figure à vous que la
note est bonne Konaté 8 varan 7 parce
que donne nos journalistes du Figaro du
stade Vincent roseron vous les avez
trouvés vraiment très bon les deux
défenseurs sont trop parce que
Christophe fait Baptiste ils ont trouvé
bon visiblement
oui alors déjà Konaté il sort il a fait
un match XXL vraiment il a rassuré de
derrière c'était il sort vraiment
vraiment un match patron impressionnant
moi j'aurais mis 7 et Varane propre il
fait des bonnes interventions un peu
moins en vue j'aurais mis si c'est demi
mais voilà je vous ai mis un petit
sondage sur le cigare au point fr sur
Youtube oui non est-ce que la France va
battre l'Argentine on va voir ce qu'on
pense nos internautes et puis vous
n'hésitez pas à chaque fois qu'on cite
un joueur hop vous donnez la note que
vous pensez de voir lui donner le
latéral gauche et ouais Hernandez buteur
est-ce que cela monte sa note oui
j'imagine forcément la Colisée ouais moi
j'aime beaucoup ce joueur il a eu un
engagement total il a une réussite un
but compliqué à mettre
acrobatique et puis franchement il a il
a tenu bon il est marocains étaient très
très solides sur son côté moi j'ai été
séduit puis j'aime cet engagement moi je
lui mets 8 bon 8 pour Hernandez et vous
moi quand même
moi je trouve qu'il a quand même
beaucoup souffert il a fait un match à
la théorie en anglaise
très bon offensivement il marque un but
il a il est monté plein de fois sur son
côté on l'a beaucoup vu mais il a eu
aussi beaucoup de mal à le boucler
défensivement donc moi j'aurais mis
cette bon tiens à l'envoi Timothée
Delhaize il est sur les Champs-Élysées
on est en train de noter les joueurs de
l'équipe de France demandez-lui qui a
été le meilleur joueur pour lui et puis
après bon l'émotion évidemment
l'emportera j'en suis sûr c'est ma tête
bien sûr justement c'est prévu Guillaume
qui a suivi ce match pas très loin des
Champs-Élysées Guillaume un pronostic
enfin pas un pronostic un avis sur ce
match on fait justement l'évaluation là
sur le Figaro live qu'est-ce que vous
avez trouvé de bon ce soir ou de moins
bon moi j'ai trouvé vraiment très bon
théorlandaise juste derrière Kylian
Mbappé j'ai trouvé l'a fait un super
match défensivement et offensivement bah
notamment avec sa réalisation son but
j'ai aussi trouvé très intéressant
l'apport de Griezmann qui est
franchement un des meilleurs joueurs sur
cette Coupe du Monde et voilà super
match on est en finale et c'est parti
let's go pour la troisième étoile là ça
y est c'est parti on a beaucoup parlé
d'Olivier Giroud ce soir qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de son match Giroud il a
beaucoup apporté bah notamment parce
qu'il a fait un rôle de pivot comme il
est connu il a permis notamment de
pouvoir créer des espaces donc pour
baper Dembélé mais aussi sur le but de
Théo Hernandez il permet de créer un
espace qui est quand même important pour
qu'il soit tout seul et que je puisse
marquer bon vous juste avant l'interview
là que vous avez vous habitez en région
parisienne vous êtes venus exprès sur
les Champs-Élysées ce soir quel est le
programme de la soirée là pour vous ah
le problème de la soirée est très simple
faire la fête rester avec tout le monde
avec tout le peuple français pour une
super soirée et pareil pour dimanche
hein dimanche on espère retourner sur
les Champs-Élysées et pour la troisième
en espérant encore une fois on va la
gagner cette coupe du monde on va bien
sûr on va la gagner ça y est on a dormi
ici mais ça y est il faut la gagner on
adore mais c'est bon dimanche prochain
3e étoile vous allez voir merci beaucoup
voilà Thibault pour cette réaction d'un
supporter français qui croit dur comme
fer pour la finale dimanche prochain et
on entend la Marseillaise derrière vous
ça c'est parfait on aime beaucoup et
bien les programmes simples comme ça
faire la fête voilà comme ça les choses
sont claires allez on passe au milieu de
terrain toi béni que de Chris je voulais
pas donner la note qu'on donnait
Baptiste et Christophe à Théo Hernandez
6 auteur d'un but éminemment pression au
tout début comme tu as notamment pour le
reste il a tenté d'exister offensivement
mais à surtout subi un certain nombre de
vagues sur de son côté le côté fort de
l'équipe du Maroc et celui de Kylian
Mbappé oui c'est vrai et il est obligé
d'une certaine manière de défendre pour
deux bon Aurélien la note que vous lui
donnez les amis cinquième et demi 5 et
demi notre mais on est qualifié s'agonie
ce soir bon et vous Cindy
Vincent sur place soit mini
bon parfois un peu neutre non alors il a
son poste ah si cette année
il sort des ballons dangereux il s'en
sort bien il y a quelques petits
problèmes à des moments je suis d'accord
mais oh si c'est une nuit ça me
paraîtrait pas pas trop bien
pour nos envoyer spéciaux prestation
inégale de la sentinelle madrilène
capable de monter rageuse au départ sur
le deuxième but mais aussi de perdre de
balles dangereuse Vincent je vous donne
pas la parole sur fofan vous l'avez déjà
massacré vous avez la parole Cédric
Canier défendez-le essayer de lui donner
une bonne note parce que je vous le dis
tout de suite elle est pas très bonne
sur Le Figaro.fr moi je lui Rémi 6 6 moi
j'ai trouvé que un peu brouillon dans
l'utilisation du ballon mais combatif
présent là dans le la dans les duels il
a touché beaucoup de beaucoup de balles
il a détourné beaucoup de de
d'offensive adverse donc moi j'ai trouvé
moi j'aurais mis 6 je donne la réaction
de Didier Deschamps parce que il s'est
exprimé il sélectionneur des Bleus on va
la voir ensemble forcément satisfait de
cette victoire il y a de l'émotion de ça
fait un mois qu'on est ensemble avec les
joueurs c'est jamais simple mais ça a
été du bonheur jusqu'à présent Didier
Deschamps qui ne s'emballe pas
évidemment ça reste un winner dans la il
connaît la chanson Fofana vous lui
donnez quelle note Cindy
5000 pour moi c'est c'est le même genre
de niveau de
jeu ce soir moi je trouve les émotions
les fumigènes sur les Champs-Élysées ça
c'est bien on aime bien ça 4 la note de
départ sur le travail ils ont pas aimé
et ils disent qu'il y a de la radio
forfait peut dormir tranquille et
s'attend à retrouver sa place pour la
finale s'il est remis attention
c'est très intéressant ça pourrait être
très inquiétant
c'est c'est oui neuf alors l'homme du
match pour nous on en a parlé Antoine
Griezmann tiens Jacoby Martin combien
vous lui donnez moi je vais aller très
très très très attention la note 9 parce
que je l'ai je il a été impérial lui
aussi il est allé oppressive il a
rameuté l'équipe c’est
l’âme ça a été l'âme ce soir ça déjà été
le cas
depuis 4 ans
de compte se pressing qu'il a pu faire à
empêcher les Marocains d'avancer et de
doubler le nombre de d'attaques
dangereuses qu'ils auraient pu faire je
trouve qu'il est absolument exceptionnel
sur cette Coupe du Monde jamais deux
sans trois étoiles nous dit Chloé 4 non
cette expression 1 allez la note sur les
Argentins sont dans la même situation
et oui et oui oui vous avez de bonnes
réaction vous êtes sur tous les ballons
d'ailleurs là vous devez Antoine
Griezmann je partage l'opinion de
Jacquot Olivier par contre il lui manque
l'action décisive
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que ça pourrait monter plus
haut malheureusement on le note encore
comme un attaquant si ce soir on note
comme un milieu
8 offensif quand même c'est une école
Ménez
la régularité des joueurs de l'équipe de
France et largement on peut se dire que
c'est un œuf pour son match mais même à
9 pour sa coupe du monde il est la
locomotive de l'équipe de France je
pense que sur la banquette en face il
rajoute un point pour l'ensemble
et je peux le comprendre je vous
l'accorde pour cela
Iron Man donne une note à Griezmann 12
voilà ce qui nous dit oui il a été
vraiment il donne les points que vous ne
donnez pas est-ce que vous pour vous
Vincent roseron Antoine Griezmann vu du
stade cette fois puisque tout est très
différent vu de la télé ou vu des
tribunes est-ce que pour vous aussi
c'est l'homme du match ce soir
oui je pense que clairement c'est
l'homme du match on pourrait mettre
Mbappé qui est à l'origine des deux buts
aussi et mais Griezmann ça a été
incroyable pendant ce match une fois de
plus son activité au milieu de terrain
pour défendre ce qu'il comprenait la
tactic adverse il est replacer
constamment c'est partenaires et on l'a
vu défendre sauver des ballons dans sa
surface à défendre comme un 6 c'est
impressionnant la polyvalence d'Antoine
Griezmann sur ce match clairement
effectivement moi je il est homme du
match il y a pas trop aller voir plus
loin bon 8 la note qu'on donnait nos
envies spéciaux tiens le sondage que
j'ai lancé sur sur Youtube ça fait 8
minutes il y a beaucoup de votants la
France va-t-elle battre l'Argentine en
finale selon vous c'est OUI à 81 % voilà
est-ce qu'on veut ou est-ce qu'on les
pronostics j'ai dit Vatel bat
l'Argentine en finale les deux se
confondent en général
allez en avance alors celui que vous
avez vous cette fois massacrer tout à
l'heure au spam Dembélé vous lui donnez
quelle note autant que le nombre de
ballons touché par le nez Siri 3
c'est une demi-finale de Coupe du Monde
il a pas la mienne on a des gens face au
Bousquet il est pas défendable sur ces
matchs mais je vais dire 5 parce que il
n'a pas non plus été complètement c'est
aussi en face ce qu'il avait en face qui
peut-être la conduit et les changements
des positionnement aussi des débats en
fait il fallait aussi qu'il puisse se
retrouver donc je pense que tout ça a dû
jouer je lui donne un sac et vous la
collier
alors comme je viens qu'une fois que
j'ai donné un œuf pour l'ensemble de son
œuvre à grisbal je vais te donner trois
à
Dembélé parce que moi je l'avais trouvé
je n'avais vraiment surpris sur le
premier match avec Théo Hernandez
derrière il y avait vraiment c'était
irlandais je crois c'est l'autre côté
donc je sais plus qui c'était mais ça
fonctionnait très très
depuis bah moi on attend que ce garçon
finisse par déborder et marquer ou
déborder ou qui montre ce qui montre à
Barcelone ou il est par moment juste
prodigieux quoi sur le cigare
commence à rentrer symbiose avec avec
mes collègues ça me fait plaisir ça y
est on se trouve une autre question sur
Youtube vous n'hésitez pas quelle est la
force de défense sa chance ou son génie
tactique j'attends votre réponse
99,9 là-dessus sur le génie tactique
bien sûr c'est mal parti sous les yeux
allez-y vous réagissez vous n'hésitez
pas tiens Vincent roseron Mbappé parce
que c'est intéressant et on fait vite
comme ça on finit avec les notes Mbappe
vous lui donnez combien ce soir
[Musique]
je pense parce que c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué à noter parce qu'il fait il
amène les deux buts mais c'est pas sur
des passes mais il est toujours
dangereux il est toujours remuant et en
même temps il a pas eu non plus à je
sais pas comment dire mais c'est pas lui
qui marche donc du coup on s'attend
toujours à mieux de lui mais si c'est
lui ça me paraît très bien si c'est la
note de Vincent Rozon sur le terrain
japonais Martin Mbappé est-ce que quand
on est décisif comme ça la note monte
forcément ou on est obligé de voir que
tout le monde moi je mettrais plutôt 6
le ce que j'ai observé moi qui m'a un
petit peu gêné je repense toujours au
match d'hier c'est qu'un Messie a été à
l'attaque à l'avant et a défendu ce
qu'on voit pas souvent au PSG du reste
là le papier que j'ai vu voilà à chaque
fois qu'on observait envoyé un Griezmann
qui venait au pressing on voit une même
Dembélé Giroud
c'est la star c'est à dire que
effectivement il est très bon pas grand
chose
d'accélérer
parce qu'il est frais bon moi je
m'attends au mieux des choses si on sait
que certains sélectionneurs qui disent
il y avait une interview que j'ai lu il
y a pas longtemps de yurijorkaeff qui
ouais mais Jaquet il disait non je veux
pas que tu défendes non non tu
te veux là je te veux dans cette zone je
veux pas que tu ailles t'épuiser voilà
donc est-ce que des champs c'est une
demande aussi maintenant c'est vrai que
que comme vous le dites on le voit pas
beaucoup d'efforts non plus à Paris qui
donne un Mbappe donc
je sais pas si tous ces entraîneurs lui
demandent de pas défendre je sais pas on
va voir si on peut retrouver dans un
instant Timothée on va me dire dans
l'oreillette parce qu'on voit les images
des Champs-Élysées qui se remplissent la
France est en finale de la Coupe du
Monde ce sera dimanche face à
l'Argentine en feeling notez les Bleus
combien vous lui donnez à bapé moi je
l'ai dit 6 et demi et je pense que c'est
effectivement des demandes peut-être des
déchets au système tactique mais il faut
pas oublier que dans les matchs
précédents on entendait pas mal des
champs criées dire répertoire etc donc
je sais pas je reste assez mitigé et on
a beaucoup d'attente très fortes mais il
a fait un très bon match donc si c'est
des mots face à une équipe qui penche
autant à droite le peu d'appétence du
Parisien pour le repli défensif se fait
grandement sentir voilà ce que nous
disent Christophe et Baptiste qui disent
quand même il est néanmoins impliqué les
deux buts tricolores il lui donne la
note de 5 le dernier joueur qui nous
n'avons pas donné oui
qui était décisif tiens avant de noter
Giroud oublié on lit ce que nous dit
Walid le sélectionneur de l'équipe du
Maroc contre une équipe comme la France
la moindre erreur se paye cash c'est
beaucoup mieux en seconde période même
si le deuxième but nous tue ça n'enlève
pas tout ce que nous avons tout ce qu'on
a donné avant oui c'est vrai que le
Maroc a été brillant et restera dans
l'histoire de la Coupe du monde comme le
premier pays africain avoir atteint les
demi-finales Olivier Giroud tiens
Vincent roseron la note que vous lui
donnez
Olivier Giroud 4 parce que il fait pas
grand chose lors de ce match on pourrait
même lui mettre trois je pense mais il
fait pas grand chose pendant ce match il
a une il a une occasion où il faudrait
qu'il contrôle sur la perséven Mbappe
qui lui revient dessus il contrôle il la
mettrait au fond il se précipite on
comprend vraiment pourquoi il essaie de
la mettre en une touche c'est assez
compliqué ce qui tente il a mis à côté
et à cause de ça on souffre alors qu'il
aurait pu vraiment mettre le doubler
très rapidement donc voilà moi je lui
mettrais pas plus de 4 en tout cas c'est
sûr d'accord vous êtes dur à Olivier
Giroud mais c'est vrai il a pas été très
bon ce soir Cindy combien la note que
vous donnez Olivier Giroud la moyenne la
moyenne mais je vous sens sympathique ce
soir
c'est Nicole ménage elle est dure avec
l'équipe de France ça m'étonne d'elle ce
soir
mais non non je pense qu'il est pas là
pour la Olivier Giroud c'est un très
grand Jorge et c'est un peu dans les
mêmes sens que Mbappé c'est à dire qu'on
a une attente forte et effectivement il
aurait dû peut-être tuer ces matchs
avant donc voilà je reste dans la
moyenne 5 les amis combien vous donnez
Olivier Giraud et je mettrai entre les
deux donc quatre et demi il a pas été
très aidé
au niveau 2018 moi je mets 4 voilà c'est
la note qu'on donnait nos envoyer
spéciaux 4 Olivier Giroud match
compliqué pour le meilleur buteur de
l'équipe de France allez on se projette
il y a un match dimanche Vincent roseron
vous avez vu l'Argentine vous avez vu la
France selon vous qui est favori de
cette finale de la Coupe du monde
dimanche
c'est très compliqué comme réponse on
est vraiment sur un 50/50 ou un 50/50
on le refait vous me donnez un avis
éclairé d'un journaliste sur place
engagé Vincent Rozon qui est favori de
la finale de la Coupe du monde dimanche
les deux équipes se valent vraiment un
avis éclairé les deux se valent vraiment
aller plus davantage pour la France mais
l'Argentine j'ai vu le premier match
contre l'Arabie Saoudite c'était très
compliqué et il monte vraiment en
puissance tout au long de cette
compétition ça va être très dur il voilà
et maintenant ils sont en place Lionel
Messi il évolue sur une autre planète il
est clairement en mission comme on dit
avec la formule un peu facile mais la
France a ses armes la France est
complète et l'Argentine par contre ça va
pas très très vite derrière et donc ça
peut être quand même pas mal pour notre
petit Mbappe pour attaquer cette équipe
de France qui affronte cette équipe
d'Argentine est-ce que c'est la finale à
rêver il y avait France - Brésil là on
avait vu qui nous donnait envie et le
France Argentine quoi jacobine
franchement c'est magnifique
de coupe du monde c'était mon souhait
France Brésil bien sûr ou France
Argentine moi je suis vraiment très très
heureux ces deux grandes équipes chacune
va concour pour sa troisième étoile ils
vont avoir un appétit foulé les
Argentins moi j'avais été déçu de la
défaite contre l'Allemagne il y a
quelques années c'était quoi il y a 8
ans
du monde et donc voilà après bon je vais
me risquer moi je j'ai l'impression que
la France est invincible quand on a
cette réussite
ils arrivent à il s'est un peu plus leur
niveau de jeu moi j'ai un souvenir de
les 20 premières minutes contre
l'Angleterre il y avait un niveau de jeu
des deux côtés d'une très très grande
qualité si on joue à ce niveau là et
qu'on a cette réussite et il faut la
réussite pour gagner une Coupe du Monde
moi je pense qu'on peut gagner alors
après je vais terminer là-dessus ces
deux équipes que j'aime beaucoup alors
mon cœur et je sais pas pourquoi les
Français aiment autant les Argentins
oui mais alors j'ai l'impression à
chaque fois chaque début de Coupe du
monde les français espèrent alors il y a
Messi maintenant et on espère tous que
du joueur comme Messi Ronaldo puisse
avoir gagné la Coupe du Monde ce sera
Ronaldo
ils ont fait une belle coupe du monde
quand même parce qu'après ce premier
match moi on s'était tous dit vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir et ils ont
montré ce qui pouvait faire et là
franchement on a envie d'une belle
finale allez on a envie de moi je parie
sur trois deux allez sur grand match
dans un instant sur l'Argentine parce
que vous allez devoir vous expliquer
devant la France entière et devant les
internautes du Figaro Cédric est-ce que
d'autres supporters que les supporters
français seront pour la France non le
monde entier va être pour pour Lionel
Messi je pense que c'est tout toute la
symbolique de ce match et tout on sait
que c'est très très vraisemblablement sa
dernière Coupe du monde mais ça va être
oui je pense que je suis assez d'accord
avec Vincent un match moi je trouve que
la France après les quarts de finale
j'aurais dit que la France a été
favorite après c'est demi-finale il y a
une vraie montée en puissance de
l'équipe argentine on sent que Messi a
l'air d'être moi je l'ai jamais vu comme
ça
il a presque de la haine dans le regard
à lui pour donner même pas pour eux et
jacques Olivier parlait de la Russie de
la France je trouve que l'Argentine est
assez bien vernis aussi là dessus même
si j'ai vu des polémiques sur les
penalty pour moi il y avait des penalty
hier mais ils ont presque un penalty par
match le but d'alvarès il a plusieurs
voilà on a on a l'impression que
l'Argentine aussi est porté par par par
quelque chose de de grand comme Messi si
vous voulez je sais pas je vais être
métaphysique ou un truc comme ça c'est
une école ménardes dimanche prochain
serez-vous supportrice de l'équipe
d'Argentine ou de l'équipe de France de
l'équipe de France évidemment vous
gagnez votre place et vous revenez mais
non mais il y a quelque chose qui
voulait
j'avais dit que je voyais
ais porter cette coupe du monde parce
qu'on voit un balai collectif et une
passion une envie on a même vu mais si
c'est métamorphosé prendre un caractère
jamais vu sur le terrain mais l'équipe
de France m'a vraiment bluffé je les
voyais parce que vous vous voyez faire
une demi finale aller jusqu'à cette
phase de la compétition ça c'est le
moment il y a un autre point aussi c'est
que la France a une expérience récente
qui pour moi la rendre favorite pour
remporter cette Coupe du monde après
tous ces statistiques elles peuvent très
bien être défaites je pense que il y a
une grande envie des messies de
remporter sa coupe du monde et tous les
joueurs du haut pour Messi c'est une
réalité ils ont déjà des qualités comme
Alvarez les joueurs de River Plate club
que je connais très bien parce que c'est
mon club de cœur en fait c'est un club
d'Argentine avec des ambulances
absolument extraordinaire dans l'espace
et effectivement partir du moment je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de des choses
autour de ces matchs il y a une image
qui m'a beaucoup marqué qu'on a vu sur
les réseaux sociaux récemment on a vu
les supporters se déplacer à la maison
de la grand-mère de Lionel Messi à
rosalio pour aller faire la fête et
lycée l'année Lionel Messi et donc la
dame est saluée dans la fenêtre on voit
une ferme mais qui est hallucinante la
gentille est un vrai pays de football et
si elle venait à marquer à gagner la
Coupe du monde mais alors là je vous dis
pas l'Argentine en plus en plus un pays
qui a un niveau d'inflation des cas
Simon c'est important ils s'en ont
vraiment besoin ils en ont besoin par
exemple les Brésil il est passé à côté
je trouve c'est important de quelque
chose sur des plus grands Brésil n'aime
pas cette équipe c'est très particulier
ils sont pas fans de leurs joueurs il y
a quelque chose là surtout les maillots
a été beaucoup porté par bolsonaro a été
un peu utilisé comme étendard politique
et je trouve que c'était vraiment
l'occasion de réconcilier ces Douans et
on est passé vraiment à côté quelque
chose
même entre Messi et tout il y a une
incompréhension et puis ils ont gagné
ils ont gagné la Copa América l'année
dernière
c'est la première Coupe du monde sans
Maradona enfin depuis le décès de
Maradona tiens il est encore tout à
l'heure tout est en place pour avoir un
grand match j'ai cru que vous me disiez
que tout est en place pour que
l'Argentine gagne dimanche
6 fois en finale l'Argentine et deux
fois Lionel Messi et d'aidant d'un
demi-finale donc je pense que là ils
peuvent aller vraiment feu d'artifice
sur les champs je vous coupe Cédric
parce que beaucoup ça déjà les feux
d'artifice et puis je voulais vous lire
la déclaration du Fofana il est encore
ce dernier dimanche aller chercher il
faudra rester focus ce sera un gros
morceau c'est une finale de Coupe du
monde rien que ça Vincent oui mais
est-ce qu'on lui demande beaucoup plus
non mais de se rappeler que c'est une
finale de Coupe du Monde c'est une bonne
chose c'est important qu'il le sait
c'est un dernier match Vincent vous
allez pas commencer à critiquer les les
joueurs de foot de l'équipe de France
qui sont en finale de la Coupe du Monde
c'est quand même la revanche du plus
beau match de la Coupe du Monde 2018 de
l'avènement de cette génération de
l'avènement de Mbappé on se souvient de
cette rencontre extraordinaire et de ce
but de Benjamin Pavard il y a 4 ans 5
ans
et oui ça c'est sûr on signe directement
pour avoir le même match pour avoir la
même pour la même victoire côté français
c'était un match incroyable c'était le
match qui avait vraiment lancé l'équipe
de France après sa phase de poule et qui
leur avait dit que voilà après ça c'est
forcément il pouvait aller au bout on
avait vu une équipe qui pouvait avec
toutes les qualités qu'elle avait et ce
qui est sûr c'est que le match ici là on
a vu un Maroc France avec la France qui
joue à l'extérieur mais je peux vous
dire que la finale ça va être à peu près
pareil voire pire j'ai vu le match le
quart de finale Pays-Bas contre
l'Argentine je pense qu'il y avait un
Néerlandais pour 10000 argentins
vraiment le ratio était fou on entendait
que dans le stade hier c'était
exactement pareil on entendait que alors
que les Croates étaient quand même un
peu venus en nombre aussi voilà donc
clairement j'espère que les Français
sont habitués à avoir le flic contre eux
parce que ça va être encore le cas
Charles Martel qui me dit contre
l'Argentine Mbappé sera décisif de but
de Mbappe oui peut-être peut-être on
l'espère je vous donne les résultats du
petit sondage que j'ai lancé quelle est
la force de Deschamps ça change ça 36%
sont génialctiques à 64%
qui sont perdus mais prenez les parles
avant
les endroits dernière question parce que
ça ça m'inquiète un peu l'absence
d'Adrien rabiot aujourd'hui sur le
terrain d'accord a-t-il le covid Cédric
allier alors on est pas sur place et que
vous me donnez pas j'ai discuté avec nos
envoyés spéciaux et tout donc il y a un
vrai doute en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que il n'était pas présent
sur le banc il est même pas monté dans
le dans le car pour aller au stade donc
il y a une entre guillemets c'est vrai
qu'on aille on s'est tellement habitué
ces dernières années à se confinement
cette isolement ça ressemble à ça
maintenant dans quelle mesure il aurait
pu l'attraper on sait pas mais mais en
tout cas je pense que demain il y aura
beaucoup de questions au sujet de radio
parce que
parce que c'est ça peut être une bombe à
retardement pour l'équipe de France si
vous avez un covidé dans le groupe
Vincent roserand dites-moi sur place
est-ce que vous avez des des échos de ce
qu'il se passe autour du cadre radio
et ben j'ai les mêmes sources que Cédric
cahier donc du coup ça va être un peu
compliqué mais effectivement il n'était
pas au stade aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
il n'a pas fait il l'a pas fait de test
donc on pourra pas on peut pas savoir et
voilà merci Vincent si vous avez des
informations n'hésitez pas à nous le
dire je sais que c'est difficile
inquiet sur le cadre radio parce que si
toute l'équipe de France venait à être
confiné ou malade
on aurait du mal contre l'Argentine
dimanche ça pas été trop le cas dans
cette Coupe du monde d'ailleurs pour
l'instant il y a pas d'équipe qui ont
été touchées
c'est qu'elle est covid en maintenance à
cogner un petit peu plus fort faut lui
dire donc je pense pas que ce soit
impossible qu'il puisse être malade
Fabio et puis éventuellement revenir
surtout que c'est une finale je pense
qu'il a envie de la jouer mais en tout
cas l'équipe de France est
rabiodépendant je compense non non c'est
les parcours
moi je partage pas tout à fait cette
analyse je trouve qu'on a eu on a vu
contre l'Angleterre qu'on pouvait gagner
s'en battait là on a gagné 100 radios
voilà la marée inquiétude c'est quand
Griezmann a pris un Carton contre les
Anglais là je me suis dit la France sans
Griezmann ça ça me fait très peur quel
est le joueur de qui manquerait le plus
à l'équipe de France pour moi c'est
Griezmann
sur la même son même niveau et même même
en défense centrale je trouve que Varane
il est c'est pas le meilleur mais il
stabilise si on devait mettre moi j'ai
trouvé upamecano et Konaté excellent sur
la Coupe du monde si on doit les mettre
les deux ensemble
je pense qu'il faut qu'il Varane Varane
avec l'un des deux et ça pousse l'autre
donc il y en a beaucoup qui sont qui
sont indispensables mais mais bon les
Argentins sans Messie voilà mais moi je
veux absolument que mes 6 sont au final
je te montre soit là ça va être une
finale je vous la non stibo à dimanche
je serai très heureux ici et soit sur un
nuage chez l'équipe de France gagne soit
sur moins sur un mais quand même si mes
cigarettes
quoi qu'il arrive
mais c'est une finale extraordinaire
moi aussi je serais triste j'adore mais
bon ça vous consolera un peu c'est si je
sais plus qu'il a dit je crois que
c'était Louis Enrique le sélectionneur
espagnol qui avait dit si on ne gagne
pas la Coupe du monde j'aimerais que ça
soit Messi ben moi si c'est pas nous qui
la gagnons
et donc quoi qu'il arrive là ça va se
passer vous retournez votre veste à tous
les coups Michel Argentine dernière
espoir pour Messi oui dernière chance
probable
on met un peu d'ambiance sur les
Champs-Élysées parce que visiblement il
y a du monde est-ce qu'on peut mettre
cette image en plein écran mettre du son
et puis en écoute ce qui se passe sur
les champs
voilà sur les Champs-Élysées on va
essayer de retrouver notre envoyé
spécial on est ensemble encore un petit
moment vous réagissez vous n'hésitez pas
à Vincent roseron vous votre avis est-ce
que le monde entier selon vous sera pour
Lionel Messi dimanche
oui j'en ai bien peur j'ai bien
l'impression que tout le monde serait
quand même très content que Lionel Messi
pour sa dernière Coupe du Monde remporte
ce trophée ce serait quand même
magnifique pour lui pour sa carrière
l'équipe n'a jamais réussi à la gagner
lui qui était passé effectivement pas
loin en 2014 en arrivant en finale donc
oui il y a beaucoup de gens qui espèrent
je pense que l'Argentine gagne comme je
vous l'ai dit sur place il y a aussi
énormément énormément de gens dans les
dans les stades qui sont qui sont
pro-argent ça il y a beaucoup de
supporters argentins partout clairement
dimanche ça va être une ambiance de
folie et tout le monde sera derrière
gentil beaucoup plus que derrière la
France et Mbappé
c'est en complétement acquis à la cause
de Lionel Messi à l'Argentine ah oui
très très nombreux c'est hallucinant
mais c'est la fièvre pour l'Argentine et
pour Messi dépasse parfois un peu dans
ton monde
que la France a gagné il y a quatre ans
et que souvent on aime bien quand ça
change
pas vous savez on n'aime pas trop le
soutien sur le Tour de France on n'aime
pas quand c'est trop souvent le même par
exemple nous on aimerait bien que ça
soit toujours les mêmes mais je pense
que dans les pays étrangers
les 14 fois les 14 victoires parce que
plus la soirée avance plus vous tombez
dans siège vous y êtes bien mon cher
Cédric je suis en train de je suis en
train de digérer cette magnifique
qualification et cette finale qui arrive
et je commence à me dire que je vais
bien alors regarder comme ça vous avez
raison et j'espère que vous serez là
dimanche bien sûr merci de nous suivre
évidemment allez on va rejoindre
Timothée delhem qui est sur place ah
peut-être pas il est en train de se
préparer parce que je veux qu'il nous
raconte l'ambiance sur les
Champs-Élysées on espère vraiment que
que ça se passe bien si Timothée il est
là je vous vois mon cher Timothée
racontez-moi l'ambiance j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a du monde est-ce
que ça se passe bien
[Musique]
ça se passe bien ça se passe voilà vous
le voyez
ça se passe si bien qu'on a dû
s'éloigner tellement il y a du monde et
donc on a des problèmes de réseau des
problèmes de connexion je ne sais pas si
vous m'entendez derrière tout ce parfums
on se trouve actuellement avenue de
Friedland pour ceux qui connaissent un
petit peu le le coin sur les
Champs-Élysées on est on a remonté tous
les Champs-Élysées depuis la place
ruelle jusqu'à l'Arc de Triomphe et je
peux vous dire que vraiment on piétine
on a énormément de mal à avancer
tellement il y a de monde actuellement
sur les Champs-Élysées avec des tirs de
fumigène des pétards quelques tirs de
mortier sous le regard des des policiers
des CRS et également de la gendarmerie
civile qui sont très très attentifs
quelques heures malheureusement sont à
déplorer mais pour l'instant la
situation est plutôt tenue ici sur les
Champs-Élysées l'ambiance et malgré tout
à la fête avec beaucoup de drapeau
français beaucoup également de slogans
beaucoup de honneurs final comme vous
l'avez entendu quelques marseillaise
également voilà
[Musique]
alors ce que le programme des Bleus
jusque là normalement alors le lendemain
de match ça fait deux fois qu'on les a
qu'on les a pas et qui sont en jour off
donc c'est possible que demain il n'y
ait pas de conférence de presse par
contre vendredi forcément conférence de
presse et samedi c'est déjà la veille de
match donc ce sera la conférence de
presse de l'île Deschamps et de Hugo
Lloris a priori même c'est quasiment sûr
le capitaine qui vient avant samedi donc
c'est conférences la conférence de
presse d'avant match il y aura la petite
finale de l'autre côté entre le Maroc et
la Croatie et la grande finale le
dimanche et effectivement Mbappé qui
s'exprime bah s'il n'est pas venu jusque
là je pense pas que sur les trois
derniers jours ici il viendra non tiens
la France aura un jour de moins de
récupération on a bien fait de s'imposer
en 90 minutes honnêtement c'est pas de
refus ce petit repos supplémentaire
parce que ça peut jouer après autant de
temps bon est-ce que vous le sentez bien
dimanche
oui non
je le sens bien après je vous ai pas dit
pour quelle équipe
[Rires]
parce que je sais que vous êtes là
dimanche avec moi donc j'attendrai
l'avant match pour vous demander au
dernier moment ce que vous pensez de ce
match allez dernière indiscrétions
est-ce que tous les jours seront là
est-ce que la France entière craindra en
covid dans le vestiaire des Bleus on a
certitude jacques Olivier Martin merci
d'être venu vous vous sentez bien pour
dimanche invincible
voilà le mot retient de la soirée Cédric
de sport merci d'être venu merci à vous
merci tout le monde merci
je suis heureux
il va devoir et de vivre ça au final de
Coupe du Monde Mbappé Messi exactement
bon Vincent rosereau merci beaucoup je
suis un peu déçu de pas vous avoir vu
avec un bonnet de coq mais je vous
préviens tout de suite si nous sommes
champion du monde dimanche vous n'aurez
pas le choix et il faudra le mettre
merci Vincent merci de nous avoir suivi
rien de Becky en régie qui orchestré
tout ça Julien Leclerc à préparer tout
tous les éléments Augustin Moriaux qui
abat un travail dingue pour organiser
ses émissions Vincent Roy la direction
toutes les équipes du Figaro sport et du
Figaro live se sont mobilisés on se
retrouve dimanche évidemment allez les
bleus encore une étape c'est historique
à dimanche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]